la nuit américaine est un film sur le
cinéma c'est l'histoire de tournage d'un
film c'est la chronique de tournage d'un
film depuis le premier jour de prise de
vue jusqu'au jour où toute l'équipe se
séparent et il fallait forcément je
crois que le site devait taper en
référence au cinéma même si l'expression
est peu connu et comme on a beaucoup
abusé à user et abuser des titres comme
moteur silence on tourne le rouge est
mis il fallait trouver autre chose et la
nuit américaine avait le mérite aussi
d'être jolie même si on ne connaît pas
le sens la nuit américaine c'est un
terme de cinéma qui désigne une prise de
vue effectuées en plein jour mais dont
le résultat sur l'écran donnera
l'impression de se passer la nuit
autrement dit on mais un filtre devant
la caméra sur l'objectif et on appelle
ça la nuit américaine
et curieusement les américains hollywood
n'ont jamais appelé ça la nuit
américaine ils appellent ça des formats
on s'est perdu ses repères dès le but
français votent rooney
s'est réchauffée ruiz on s'est séparés
chacun pour soi est reparti dans
tourbillon ma vie j'ai revu à souanyas
ya fait des longs m me weiss ça fait
déjà pas fameux bail